We have a voicemail number. That number is
two one nine two David P. this voicemail is
very timely in the context of impeachment
in the context of what we expect to be an
acquittal of Donald Trump along party lines
in the Senate. Let's take a listen.
Hey, David names landed Letterman from East
Tennessee. I just had a question about impeachment
and all this. Is that, I mean, I, I'm not
to underplay the importance of voting, but
if voting is the only means of dealing with
a corrupt president in terms of the way Donald
Trump has lived his life at all, then why
do we have a system of justice? It just seems
pointless to me that that's the only recourse.
Get back to me on this.
Yeah, no, Landon, you're completely right.
I mean, this is, this is what I've been saying
for awhile. Uh, the Mueller investigation
was never going to remove Donald Trump. Go
back and look at my videos from, I don't even
know, April of 2017. I said, if you're waiting
around for this to remove Trump, it's not
going to, uh, the 25th amendment possibility.
Uh, the cabinet, you know, if you're waiting
or I did, this is clearly a guy who was impaired,
um, either from in a medical sense or in a
colloquial sense, it's not going to work.
Impeachment, we know it's not going to remove
Donald Trump the emoluments violation. It's
not going to remove Donald Trump. So the question
Landon is asking is when we all have to contend
with which is our our systems of checks and
balances too much subject to the whims of
the party that is in control of them.
I think the answer is yes. I don't believe
that the founders ever considered when they
put these in place that a president would
simply ignore them. The checks and balances
are only as good as their enforcement and
our ability to have them enforced and the
ability is basically zero. Zilch right now.
So while I don't like to accept that this
is the reality Landon's right, that the one
way, the one opportunity to give Trump a consequence
like a parent would tell their kid, if you
do this, you're going to have a consequence.
The only opportunity is voting Trump out in
November of 2020 if he's reelected, there
will be no other consequences during his second
term and he will serve that second term and
then leave. He's not going to be indicted
after he leaves the white house. Forget that.
If people are holding out hope for that.
There's one opportunity and it's simply saying
at the ballot box, we reject you. We reject
you by such overwhelming numbers that even
foreign interference and voting machine nonsense
and all of the stuff in V D you'd have a vote
purging voter rolls. We reject you by such
overwhelming numbers that even those things
can't keep you in the oval office. It's one
opportunity Landon's right? It's a sad reality,
but that's the reality. We're dealing with
a, we are going to talk on the bonus show
today about the black Texas teen who was told
to cut his hair, his dreadlocks in order to
walk at graduation. What is all that about?
Many people outrage. We will also talk about
new research where it appears as though we
figured out why stress turns people's hair
gray. Okay, we will discuss that and in addition
to that, and New Jersey is mandating severance
pay for workers facing mass layoffs, and that
in and of itself is triggering a lot of people
who I guess don't think that the workers deserve
severance pay. All of those stories and more
on today's bonus show, become a member@joinpacman.com
to get instant access. The impeachment coupon
code is impeached 50. We are at 103 new members.
We using the impeach 50 coupon code. Help
us make it 104. We will also be continuing
our endless marathon streams of the impeachment
trial of Donald [inaudible]
Trump. Uh, if you're listening to this, we
are probably screaming right now. Come find
us on YouTube and Twitch. We will otherwise
cock you on the bonus show or on tomorrows
the David Pakman show@davidpakman.com [inaudible].